Hello, everybody. This is section eight of the beating credit like book
We have a lot to go through in this section because we really get into looking at how to trade it
Remember I said there's three phases the acute stage has that window of opportunity that you
By all means one to catch and my opinion is you would find somebody who would prescribe you antibiotics
The second stage is
Happens as soon as one of those barely a bacteria enter into a cell. How do I know that I'm not in that stage?
That's the question I get. I had antibiotics
It ducted out of me. I feel fine. Did I did I catch it in the window? The answer is you don't know yet
So you don't know it yet. Why because you knocked it out of the blood and out of the extra cellular space with that
Antibiotic and you feel fantastic
Give it some time. So if it comes back
So it came back again a two months later one once later two weeks later after I stopped taking antibiotics
You are already in the chronic stage. So you take antibiotics again. Oh my gosh. I felt so much better
I took the antibiotics and doctor right out of me again. Well
It's
Intercellular still so it's most likely going to keep coming back coming back coming back coming back and
then you are in
Problem because you can move from the chronic face to the autoimmune phase and you do that one to do that
So you want to make sure that you try to treat it with some urbels and some different protocols
Cats cost some of the things that we talked about and we'll talk about it in the next section as well
Now we're going to talk about this stage three autoimmune phase and the way to understand it is to understand the immune system
So let's go back to a little
Immune allergy
101 if you remember from your college days you have
The two distinct parts of your immune system. You have more. I talked about the TH17 response
These TH1 and TH2 come from a TH0 regulatory T cells
We're not going to get in too deep of this. So let's just keep it trying as simple as possible
So you have two made responses of your immune system your TH1 and your TH1
TH2 now normally they are in balance
Think of the TH1 side as the killer cell side and think of the TH2 side as the
FBI CIA
So the killer side the TH1 side consists of a bunch of chemokines and cytokines and
macrophages and white blood cells that their made response is to destroy
Enemy so they are the marine core of your body. You want them very healthy, but that you don't want them
You know over production so that they're looking for enemies at all the wrong places and you can develop an autoimmune issue
So normally they're in balance
So there's different out of that TH0 regulatory T cell you produce TH1 cells and TH2 cells
The TH1 like I said are respond
Body mainly to destroy pathogens the TH2 side is mainly responding to create antibodies
So therefore the TH1 side can find out where the pathogen is and kill it or randomly
So normally in your body you have a cold
Yours you have a virus that enters into your body and it circulates into your bloodstream
Your immune system senses that this pathogen is very illid so it fires a TH1
Little blurb me to you secrete more TH1 cells
Kills the pathogen everything goes back into balance. You never knew you were sick
This happens literally daily
You're exposed to pathogens. You have a little blip of your TH1 side
Kills it goes back into balance. You never felt sick. Well you weren't sick because your immune system did its job and killed it
But let's say you have the flu
It's a really nasty flu that you're exposed to you fire a TH1 response can't kill it fires higher
Can't kill it fires more. That means you have more circulated TH1 cytokines and chemokines
Still can't kill it then your TH1 side pulls down your TH2 side fires
Makes antibodies to that pathogen now your TH1 side fires again and kills that pathogen. That's normal
Immuted that's a normal immune response in a person's body
But they were sick when they were this hyper TH1 side
They had a fever they felt because bloated they didn't feel good
They would home ate some chicken soup took the day off the next day. They had a TH1 TH2 response and it
Worked and it killed that disease
That's normal
Immuted response
Okay, so when you're exposed to a pathogen like Borrelia
It goes into your body you may or may not get a rash
You have a TH1 response and fires this hyper TH1 response you feel sick you have a temperature
What is a temperature? It's an increased immune response
Flood of TH1 cytokines is a temperature good. Yes, it is. You don't want to get the temperature down
You want your TH1 side to kill the pathogen
So whatever it is you want to kill it foolish thing to do is take your kid and give him something to get their fever down
Yeah, you don't want to hire a fever, but you want a fever high enough to be able to kill that pathogen
That's a normal response of your body
So you're not yet eating autoimmune disorder yet. So you're going back and forth for this type of TH1 response to a
TH2 response in order to make antibodies to kill that that
That pathogen the problem is is that if you go back and forth like this like in a case like
Lyme disease so Lyme disease becomes autoimmune
When you fire this TH1 TH2 response TH1 TH2 response TH1 TH1 TH2 response
Dumerous times over the course of weeks and months
There's one bad thing that could happen
So every time you fire a TH2 response that TH2 cytokines are
Lucky for the enemy which the TH1 side initially fired against
So in the case of a virus you fire this TH1 response it can't kill that virus you fire a TH2 response the
TH2 cytokines find that virus and go there you are we're going to take you with an antibody
So it makes an antibody against that virus now when the TH1 response fires
Those are tagged think of an antibody like fluorescent tape around
In an enemy so now the Marine Corps could go in there go oh there it's tagged with fluorescent tape
We could go in there and find it and kill it
That's a normal response
But with a gram negative bacteria like
Borrelia
It has the ability to go inside the cells when it goes inside the cells your immune system your TH2 side
Can't find it your TH1 side can't kill it because I can't find it your TH2 side can't take it because I can't find it
So it's looking for where are there where is it we got to take it with antibodies
Where is it I know it was right around this area
This is where the TH1 cytokines are so we got to find it it's right around this area
It can't find it you do this over and over again pretty soon you start making antibodies to your old cells
That's not a good thing
When you start creating antibodies to your old cells
You know every time you fire a TH1 response
Either because you have a cold or because you're stimulated it with TH1 stimulators like
Cat's Claw Vitamin C
Echinacea Golden Seal
Things that you'll use that you will see as protocols in live disease
These are TH1 stimulators if you're going to stimulate the TH1 side of your immune system
When you already have antibodies to your old body you are helping your body kill itself
If you're going to stimulate the immune system and you already have an autoimmune issue
You are helping your body kill your old cells
You got that? It's really important if you're already in the autoimmune phase
You cannot use TH1 stimulators
Okay
So TH1 dominant patients that are autoimmune do not do well with TH1 stimulators
Matter of fact I said do not do well. They'll have symptoms. They don't do well
But in real life they are destroyed their cells
So if you have you have antibodies to your old cerebellum you have antibodies to your old
Violent sheath you have antibodies to your own neurons in your brain
And you fire a TH1 response by taking Echinacea Cat's Claw Vitamin C
Are there any immune stimulants most earned most stimulates
Most things that are on the market for live disease
Anything that says an immune stimulant on it you are destroyed your old cells
Guess what? Don't do it. Stop taking it
Stop treating your disease this way. If you've moved beyond the chronic phase into the autoimmune phase
Everything that you've been doing to that point out you could actually be
Aiding yourself destruction paid for it on top of that
bad move
TH1 dominant patients must consider alternate ways to treat the disease. They have to consider alternate ways to treat the disease
They can't stimulate an immune response
You cannot matter. In fact you want to suppress a TH1 response
Well, how in the world are you going to kill this disease?
Well, you're going to use things that will not stimulate a TH1 response
That's why I would recommend it'd be better if you didn't know anything
Then I'm going to share the next this the rest of this chapter and the next few chapters
Do nothing or go on antibiotics again
You know, you're going to destroy your body, but at least you're not going to you know kill your body
We use things like MMS. You read about it in this chapter
These are and other non-TH1 stimulators
One of the biggest protocols we use is energetic medicine, energy medicine
We use the rife machine. So we're going to have a whole chapter on the rife machine here
So your frequency medicine is a huge thing to kill
Lyme disease and other pathogens like mold. So same book
I could just change every word to mold
From Lyme disease and it's the same it's the same process
So you have to look at other things you have to look at other things to help strengthen brain and refire those different
Brain therapies to refire those pathways to create those
Those neurological pathways that are damaged. So take over this treat acute
phase one
Lyme disease as soon as possible with antibiotics
If you know that you are not yet in the autoimmune phase, you can try to use
immune stimulants that means
I don't think I'm in the autoimmune phase. I think I'm still in the chronic phase
Well, one of the ways you can tell I'm going to take a bunch of vitamin C
I use some vitamin C type protocol. I use a high garlic protocol. I use cat's clop protocol
And I did super well and really helped to just duct it out of me
And
Stata that really really helped you are probably still in the chronic stage. Thank goodness
Congratulations
Promise you're probably listening to this or reading this book because you tried that it didn't work because you're already on the immune
So if the use of immune stimulants has not solved your symptoms
Not solved your problems because it should solve them
There's a pretty good chance you're already autoimmune Lyme you're already in phase three
Or if your disease process is just quite aggressive
You can move into this quite quickly or if you have a previous
If previous th. What's it be? Let's have worse in your symptoms
So if you are in phase three autoimmune Lyme call our office. Listen to the rest of this book
This is the end of this little presentation
But we'll get it deep into what we do with chronic Lyme because with the autoimmune piece because those are the people that we see
All right, hope this helps. Let's do it a couple times if you have to. I know I talk super fast
I'll see you at the next section